Oh man, it is finally good to be here solo. You know, this is the way I always envisioned the podcast. And because it initially was called smart. And then when I added Sean and Jason, I had to add the less. And that was a, it was a whole thing. And they can, their whole thing is like, no, less is more. And I'm like, no, man, less is less. Anyway, welcome to smart less smart. Smart. Oh, where'd you go, Sean? Oh, so I went to go visit Will. And then I went on vacation with you. Jason. With me? When? Yes. Oh, no, Jason. My memory is not so good. Oh, Jay. Believe me. Jay, did you switch gummies? Not related, but did you switch gummies recently? Yeah, this one says memory suck on it. I got a deal. By the
天哪，终于能一个人录节目了，感觉真好。你知道，这一直是我心目中播客该有的样子。起初它叫“Smart”，后来我加上了肖恩和杰森，就不得不加上“less”，这可真是费了一番周折。他们的观点是“少即是多”，而我却觉得“少就是少”。总之，欢迎来到“SmartLess”。等等，肖恩，你去哪儿了？哦，我去拜访威尔了，然后还和你一起去度假了，杰森。和我？什么时候？是的。哦，不，杰森，我的记性不太好。哦，杰，相信我。杰，你最近换软糖吃了吗？这跟话题无关，但你最近换过软糖吗？是的，这一款上面写着“记忆力差”。我买的时候打折。顺便说一下，
way, by the way, speaking of memory suck, Sean, I don't know why it's not related, but I texted Jason last night or the night before I can't remember. Alone on discovery, that show about people being stuck out in the woods. Have you seen it? No, I want to see that. Jason's been trying to get me to watch it or both of us for a year at least. At least. Oh, yes. Jason, you told me about that. Yeah. I remember that. Dude. Is it so good? Yeah. Okay. I mean, it's kind of cinematic too, right? It's like, it gets all dark and creepy and the sounds and the little, what is it like naked and afraid or naked and afraid looks like a kind of like the difference kind of like survivor. It's kind of grab assy and you know, kind
顺便说一下，说到记忆力差，肖恩，我不知道为什么这不相关，但我昨晚或前晚给杰森发了短信，我不记得了。关于《荒野独居》那个节目，就是讲人们被困在森林里的那个。你看过吗？没有，我想看。杰森至少有一年一直在劝我或者我们俩看那个节目。至少一年。哦，是的，杰森，你跟我提过。是的，我记得。伙计，那节目真的那么好看吗？是的，而且拍得很有电影感，对吧？气氛变得阴暗诡异，还有那些声音，还有，那是什么，像《原始生活21天》吗？《原始生活21天》看起来有点像，或者说有点像《幸存者》。那节目有点胡闹，你知道，有点
of high jinksy. Yeah. That was me last night. Negative. Naked and afraid playing a lot of the grab house. I locked my keys. I locked my keys in the house and I thought everybody was skinny dipping and then, but anyway, the point is that this is people, Sean, they take 10 people, put them in the woods and whoever can last the longest with literally like a thing to not even a match. All I would think about is Blair Witch and I know, well, and there are people hilariously who are like, man, I'm going to give this bear a run for its money. And then, and then the guy doesn't even make it. They're all professional survivalists too. Wait, but dude, dude, if they're getting chased by a bear, it's like somebody from
有点恶作剧。是的，昨晚我就那样。负面。在《原始生活21天》里玩了很多恶作剧。我把钥匙锁在屋里了，我以为大家都在裸泳，但不管怎样，重点是，肖恩，这节目找了10个人，把他们扔进森林里，看谁能坚持最久，身上几乎什么都没有，连火柴都没有。我只会想到《女巫布莱尔》，我知道，而且有些人搞笑地说：“伙计，我要让这头熊吃不了兜着走。”然后，那个人连一天都没撑过去。他们也都是专业的生存专家。等等，伙计，如果他们被熊追，那就像是剧组的人介入了，但根本没有剧组。没有剧组。你有一堆GoPro，他们必须自己拍摄。你有一堆GoPro要架设。你在开玩笑吧。不，我得看看这个。这节目太棒了。简直不可思议。真的很棒。我等不及看你看到两人组的时候了。你想到的是熊，我不是在说斯科蒂，我不是在说斯科蒂。不，不，不，那不是一群人。不是熊在追我。他们还没在第21街和第8大道的Rawhide里面拍过。好吧，听着，说到第21街和第8大道，这让我想到了纽约，这是一个绝妙的过渡。伙计们，我能告诉你们一件事吗？我真的很
the crew stepped in and there's no crew. There's no crew. You got a bunch of go pros. They have to film themselves. You have a bunch of go pros you have to set up. You're joking me. No, I got to watch this. It's pretty great. It's incredible. It's pretty great. I can't wait till you get to the two man teams. You're thinking bears. You're not, I'm not talking about Scottie. I'm not talking about Scottie. No, no, no, no, no. It's not a bunch of dudes. It's not bears chasing me. They don't, they haven't shot it inside raw hide at 21st and eighth. Okay. Listen, speaking of 21st and eighth, which takes me to New York, this is a segue beyond all segues. Guys, can I tell you something? I am really
兴奋，因为我不认识这个人。我们这些年来可能打过几次照面，但我一直，我要说出来，我一直非常崇拜他的职业生涯和他所做的一切。他是熊吗？不，他是。不，不，不，他不是。他从一开始就很有才华。他从事这一行很久了，年纪和我们差不多，但我们一直都很钦佩他。他不仅拍电影，还导演电影，写剧本，写戏剧，写书，然后又回去做这做那。他做这一行真的很久了。我可以告诉你，
excited because I don't know this person. We have had a passing hello, I think a few times over the years, but he's one of those people that I've always, I'm going to say it. I've always absolutely adored his career and what he does. Is he a bear? No, he is. No, no, no, no, he's not. He is just talented from the get. He's been doing it a long time and he's about all of our age, but he's been doing it and we've all been admiring him for a really long time. Not only has he been making movies and then directing movies and then writing movies and writing plays and writing books and then going back and doing this and that. He's been doing it a really long time. I can tell you
你尊重这个人。就像，你知道，他脸上有一种特定的表情。有一种，听着，听着，听着，神秘嘉宾。在我见到你之前，要知道威尔，威尔这次可不是在敷衍。他，你对他有某种看法。是真的。他确实。他确实。他印象深刻。我一直觉得，哦天哪，那，那太棒了。他所做的一切，他真的很棒。而且他做的事情和他刚开始时相比非常不同。他总是不断尝试新东西。我觉得这是一个真正好奇且有才华的人的标志，他们不断尝试做不同的事情。我提到了书和
respect this guy. Like, you know, it's a certain look on his face. There's a certain listen, listen, listen, mystery guest. Before I meet you, just know that we'll, we'll actually is not phoning this one in. He, you've got, you've got something on him. It's true. He does. He does. He's impressed. I've always been like, oh man, that's, oh, that was so good. And everything he's done, he's really good. And he's done stuff that's been so different from, from where he started to where he is today. It's just, he's always mixed it up. And I think that that's the hallmark of somebody who's really curious and really talented that they keep trying to do different stuff. I mentioned the books and
戏剧。而且，你知道，这家伙，这家伙，他，他在他的一部电影里谈论过食人行为。他在另一部电影里站在桌子上。他试图去太空，但他没有正确的DNA。在另一部电影里。他现在，他一直在做这个，他正在做这个新系列，我想是在Disney+上，对吧？他正在Netflix上拍一部电影。最重要的是，他导演了一部关于保罗·纽曼的新纪录片。欢迎他。是伊桑·霍克。什么？
the plays. And, you know, I mean, this guy, this guy, he, he, he versed on cannibalism in one of his movies. He, he stood on top of his desk and another one of his movies. He was trying to get to space, but he didn't have the right DNA. Another one of his movies. He's now got, he's, he's been doing this, he's doing this new series over on, I guess on Disney plus that's that right now. He's doing a film on Netflix. He's got most importantly a new documentary that he directed that is about Paul Newman. Join the word. It's Ethan Hawke. What?
不会吧。天哪。伊桑·霍克。嘿，伙计们。天哪。早上好。等等，伊桑，我刚看了《黑色电话》。是叫这个名字吗？就是这个名字。你说对了。我昨晚刚看完。我一直在跟所有人推荐它。你在那部电影里太棒了。
No way. Oh my God. Ethan Hawke. Hey guys. Oh my God. Good morning. Wait, Ethan, I just watched the black phone. Is that what it's called? That's what it's called. You got it right. I just watched it last. It's, I've been telling everybody about it. You're amazing in that
好吧，谢谢。是的，我喜欢那部电影。我很高兴能得到威尔如此正式的介绍。我感到很荣幸。你让肖恩·海耶斯露出了真诚的笑容。他平时大多是装出来的。笑容对他来说很容易，但那是真心的。哇。见到你真是荣幸。
movie. Well, thanks. Yeah. I love that movie. I just want to see it. I'm glad I got a legit intro from Will. I feel honored. You got a legit smile out of Sean Hayes. He's usually faking it. Most of the time. Smiles come easy to him, but that's genuine. Wow. It's such a pleasure and honor to meet you.
真的。我是说，伊桑，我们从来没真正见过面。我们，我不知道你记不记得，我们有一次在西村的街上读到过对方。你可能不记得了。在Rawhide？是的，Rawhide。在Rawhide。你记得吗？是的。不，我们当时，我是，你是谁？
It really is. I mean, Ethan, we've never really met. We, I don't know if you remember, we one time read each other on the street in the West Village. You probably don't remember. At Ruhide? Yeah, Ruhide. At Ruhide. You remember? Yeah. No, we were, I was, who are you?
等等，等等。我想你当时和舍姆在一起。我认识约翰·舍曼。是的。是的，我当时穿着一件衬衫。我穿着一件布莱恩·琼斯镇大屠杀乐队的T恤。那是大约15年前的事了，你当时走过来，我对舍姆打招呼，然后你说，嘿伙计，不错的T恤。我说，谢谢。我当时太兴奋了。
Wake, wake. I think you were with Sherm. I know John Sherman. Yeah. Yeah. I was wearing a shirt. I was wearing a Brian Jonestown massacre T-shirt. This is like 15 years ago and you just went, I said, saying hi to Sherm and then you went, Hey man, nice T-shirt. I was like, thanks. I was so psyched.
而且伊桑，伊桑当时穿着一件露脐上衣，一件很有品味的。很有品味的。是的。我昨天刚和某人谈起那部保罗·纽曼的纪录片。我迫不及待想看了。我刚开始看。我们来谈谈，伊桑，你是怎么做到的，这部纪录片？好吧，我当时，就在疫情开始前，我正从公寓的淋浴间出来，电话响了，我——肖恩抓住了重点。肖恩闭着眼睛。他抓住了。是的。是的。是的。睁开眼睛。说慢点。说慢点。不，我，我接了电话。你知道现在电话响的时候，如果你不知道对方的名字，你不应该接，你知道，因为那是，好吧，我只是决定管他呢，我接了，结果是保罗·纽曼和乔安娜·伍德沃德最小的孩子，她从朋友那里得到了我的号码，她自我介绍说，我真的很想让你导演一部关于我父母的纪录片。不错的电话。我当时，我的第一个想法是，我该怎么推掉这个？你知道，这听起来工作量太大了，而且，我跟她聊了一会儿她手头有什么资料，以及为什么她觉得这会很好。我试着推荐其他人，但她却
And Ethan, Ethan was in a tube top, a tasteful one. A tasteful one. Yeah. Now I was just talking with somebody yesterday about that Paul Newman documentary. I cannot wait to see it. I just started that. Let's talk about how, how did this, how did this happen for you, Ethan, this doc? Well, I was, it was like right before the pandemic started, I was getting out of the
说，不，威尔，我在问你。我说，好吧，我说，让我考虑一下。我实在想不出拒绝的理由。当我刚到纽约时，爱上了表演，他们，我是说，不是为了煽情，但他们有一种神一般的地位。你有时会在首映式上看到他们，而且他们两人在如此不同的领域都达到了如此高的水平，这真是事实。你知道，她有点像演员中的演员。她教表演。她痴迷于戏剧，经营着自己的剧团。而且，你知道，他是一位名副其实的电影泰斗。他们结婚50年了。所以无论
shower in my apartment and the phone rang and I- Sean's got it. Sean's eyes are closed. He's got it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Open up your eyes. Talk slower. Talk slower. No, I, I picked up the phone. You know how like now when the phone rings and you don't
你认为这不可能做到，保罗和乔安娜的形象就会出现在我的脑海里，就像，哇，你可以过上美好的生活，做一个正派的人，创作伟大的艺术，并拥有爱情。所以我基本上问了孩子们，如果我这样做，我会发现什么真正令人反感的事情吗，你知道，就像，我喜欢你们对他们的印象。完全正确。我喜欢我幻想中的版本。我想，这准确吗？他们说，是的，大致准确。总之，我实在想不出拒绝的理由。所以我答应了。然后几乎三年过去了。对。
know the person's name, you should never answer it, you know, because it's, well, I just decided what the hell, I picked it up and it turned out it was Paul Newman and Joanne Woodward's youngest child who got my number from a friend and she's like introduced herself and said, I really want you to direct a documentary about my parents. Nice call. And I based, my first thought was, how the hell do I get out of this? You know, it just sounded like so much work and, and I talked to her for a while about what she had and why she thought it would be good. And I tried to recommend some other people and she was
哇。你知道最疯狂的是你出现在这里。我一直觉得这种事很疯狂。有人两天前刚给我发短信说我出现在那部纪录片里。不会吧。是的，有一张我的照片什么的，他们剪辑到了康涅狄格州的剧院里。那不是很棒吗？真的吗？真的吗？太离奇了。然后你现在就在节目上。你为此得到报酬了吗？
like, no, well, I'm asking you. I was like, well, I was like, let me think about it for a minute. And I just couldn't figure out a way to say no. When I first arrived in New York, fallen in love with acting, they were, I mean, not to be corny, but they had kind of a God-like status. You would see them sometimes at an opening and the fact that they both had achieved at such a high level in such different ways. You know, she was kind of like the actor's actor. She was teaching acting. She was obsessed with theater and ran her own theater company. And, you know, he was a card-carrying cinema luminary. And they'd been married for 50 years. So whatever
某种出场费。是的。噢哦。我突然陷入了法律地狱。等着肖恩请律师吧。没人比肖恩·海耶斯更喜欢打官司了。等等，所以伊桑，这太神奇了。所以现在你来到了2022年，你刚刚花了过去三年的时间制作了一部关于保罗·纽曼和乔安娜·伍德沃德的纪录片。让我们真正回到年轻……继续说。继续说。
you think it can't be done, the image of Paul and Joanne would be in my brain like, wow, you could live a good life and be a decent person and make great art and have love. So I basically asked the kids if by doing this, was I going to find out anything that was really revolting, you know, like, I liked your image of them. Exactly. I loved my fantasy version. And I thought, is this remotely accurate? And they're like, yeah, it's remotely accurate. And anyway, I couldn't figure out a way to say no. So I said yes. And then almost three years went by. Right.
不错。顺便说一下，不错。所以你现在几岁？你的第一份表演工作是什么？你不是来自纽约吗？我觉得你对我来说是一个典型的纽约人。你来自哪里？你在哪里长大的？好吧，我出生在德克萨斯州奥斯汀。我父母分开了，我去了我父亲在德克萨斯的州。所以我夏天会在德克萨斯度过，我妈妈……他们分开时你多大？你多大？三岁。
Wow. You know what's so crazy that you're on here. I always think this kind of stuff is nuts. Somebody just texted me like two days ago that I'm in that. I'm in that documentary. No way. Yeah. There's like a photo of me or something that they cut to at the theater in Connecticut. Isn't that fine? Really? Really? What bizarre. And then here you are on the show. Did you get a bump for that?
哦，好吧。是的。那我们就不谈那个了。不，不。你很快就走出来了。没有痛苦。是的，三岁时没有痛苦。没有痛苦，没有痛苦。
Some sort of an appearance. Yeah. Uh-oh. I'm now all of a sudden in legal hell. Wait till Sean gets lawyered up. Nobody likes to litigate more than Sean Hayes. Wait, so Ethan, this is amazing. So now here you are at 2022 and you've just spent the last three years of your life making a documentary about Paul Newman and Joanne Woodward. And let's really rewind to young… Weave on. Weave on.
没有痛苦。我母亲经常搬家，从亚特兰大到康涅狄格，到佛蒙特，到布鲁克林，到新泽西。所以我是在新泽西高中毕业的。是一连串的银行抢劫案还是她在逃避什么？好吧，我们得问她。事实是，我出生时她才18岁。所以她试图弄清楚自己是谁，不断换工作，换身份，可以这么说。我是说，不是作为银行劫匪，不是字面意义上的身份。不，但是你能……你可以想象。我只是说，我52岁了，还在试图弄清楚我是谁。顺便说一下，太兴奋了。
Nice. By the way, nice. So now you're what? What's your first acting gig? Where are you not from New York? You feel like such a quintessential New Yorker to me. Where are you from? Where did you grow up? Well, I'm born in Austin, Texas. My parents split up and I traveled to my dad's state in Texas. So I'd spend the summers in Texas and my mom… How old were you when they split up? How old were you? Three.
但你看起来一点都不像超过35岁。你不能选角选得太老，我是说，看着它。也许，也许39岁。39岁，我是说……是的，但那是夸张了。但是……不，这很有趣。在你的介绍中，你谈到了，你在说我的好话，关于好奇心之类的。但我也有同感。我制作这部纪录片的整个过程中，
Oh, okay. Yeah. We're not going to touch that then. No, no. You got over it fast. There's no pain. Yeah, no pain at three. No pain, no pain.
我一直对剪辑师说，我不是纪录片导演。我不知道该怎么做。我是说，我不知道怎么做这个。我确实喜欢这样做，让自己处于那种拥有初学者心态的位置。是的。是的。你现在觉得离它更近了吗？你知道，我只觉得离一件事更近，那就是表演。这是我唯一了解的事情。其他的，你知道，写作，做其他事情，这是一个类似的练习。这只是讲故事，对吧？但我并不觉得离它更近。它感觉和以前一样神秘。
No pain. My mother bounced around a lot from Atlanta to Connecticut to Vermont to Brooklyn to New Jersey. So I graduated high school in Jersey. Just a series of bank robberies or what was she running from? Well, we'd have to ask her. Well, the truth is she was 18 when I was born. So she was trying to figure out who she was and kept changing jobs and changing her identity, so to speak. I mean, not as a bank robber, not literally her identity. No, but can you… You can imagine. I'm just saying that like I'm 52 and I'm still trying to figure out who I am. By the way, it's all too excited.
你导演过一些作品，不是吗？是的，很多。是的。你觉得比起导演，你对表演的吸引力更大，对吧？好吧，导演的好处是你可以选择你的素材，你可以雇佣人。所以你合作的每个人都是你喜欢相处的人。当你是一名演员时，你经常会被安排在这些片场，你会想，为什么这家伙是个混蛋？为什么她，是谁雇了她，你知道，我是说，或者你陷入了一种你真的很喜欢角色或什么的境地，但导演的构想完全不同，
But you don't play a day over 35, though. You can't cast as old an artist, I mean, just looking at it. Maybe, maybe 39. 39, I mean… Yeah, but that's a stretch. But… No, it's funny. In your intro, you were talking about, you were saying nice things about me about curiosity and things like that. But I feel that way too. The whole time I was making
你们的想象力在打架。当你导演时就不会发生这种情况。是的。好吧，我正要说，但这让我印象深刻。所以再次，就像你去做导演，导演一些纪录片，所有这些可能很大程度上是因为你演戏演得太好了。而且再次，这在节目中发生过几次，但你和杰森很相似，你们很早就开始了，你们一直坚持并做了伟大的事情。他们总是谈论童星的危险，等等。你们俩都避开了
this documentary, I kept saying to the editor, I'm not a documentary filmmaker. I don't know what to do. I mean, I didn't know how to do this. And I do enjoy doing that, putting yourself in a position where you have that beginner's mind sensibility. Yeah. Yeah. Do you feel closer to it now? You know, there's only one thing I feel close to which is acting. That's the only thing I know anything about. The other, you know, writing, doing other things, it's a similar exercise. It's just storytelling, right? But I don't feel closer to it. It feels just as mysterious as it did.
很多那种情况，保持真实并继续前进。而且你所做的一切都在不断变好，这很不寻常。这甚至不是一个问题，更多的是一种陈述或观察，但那个时刻是什么？因为我想回到之前，你第一次试镜的是什么？我是说，你记得吗，是你对你妈妈说，我需要试镜这个吗？还是她像，有一个角色可用？是的。你追求它了吗？好吧，好吧。我会告诉你，我会试着快点说。杰森，我相信你有你的
You've done some directing though, haven't you? Yeah, a bunch. Yeah. And that you feel a closer pull to acting than directing, yeah? Well, the great thing about directing is you get to choose your material and you get to hire people. So everybody that you're working with are people that you like to be around. When you're an actor, you often get set on these sets where you're like, why is this guy such an asshole? And why is she, who hired her, you know, I mean, or you get into a situation where you really like the character or something, but the director envisioned it completely different
故事，关于，你知道，童星表演很危险。所以我们一起成长的人中有很多已经死了，你知道？我是说，而且没有多少人还在靠这个谋生。我是说，我不是为了吹嘘。我只是，我为我们，为任何能以某种方式驾驭从孩子到年轻人过渡的人感到骄傲，因为这太反复无常了，而且，这与谁好无关。这只是谁能保持一种半酷的状态来被雇佣。我不是想听起来像个愤世嫉俗的人，但你知道，通常这与才华无关，我认为。
and your imaginations are like at war with each other. And that doesn't happen when you're directing. Yeah. Well, I was just going to say, but it strikes me. So again, like you get to go and you're directing some and directing a documentary some, all because probably a lot of it because of you've been so good at acting for so long. And again, this has happened a couple of times on the show, but you and Jason are similar in that you guys started young and you've continued and done great stuff. And they always used to sort of the dangers of being a child actor and blah, blah, blah. Both of you guys kind of sidestepped
好吧，这与，我不认为这与才华有关。这确实与你的一点DNA，谁抚养你，你处理失败的能力，你从失败中成长的能力有关。你知道，我前几天在电话里和玛莎·普林顿谈过，她长大后成了一个如此非凡的人。但如果你不在内心做这些事情，你的才华就会枯萎，你知道，或者它只是，它会被打压。我的第一次，我妈妈，我没有冬季运动。我妈妈直到七点才下班，所以她需要我做，你知道，我需要在冬天做点什么。
a lot of that and stayed true to and have continued. And if everything you do keeps getting better and it's, and it's unusual. And that's not even a question that's more of a statement or an observation, but what was that moment? Cause I wanted to go back before, what was, what was the first thing you auditioned for? I mean, do you remember was it, were you saying to your mom, I need to audition for this? Or was she like, there's a part available? Yeah. Did you pursue it? Well, all right. I'll tell you, I'll try to do it fast. Jason, I'm sure you have your
所以她给我报了一个在新泽西州普林斯顿的保罗·罗伯逊表演艺术中心的表演班。我去上这个课，他们请了一位客座演讲者，他做了一个即兴表演。我小时候是个大戏精。下课后，他在停车场走过来对我说，你想，他当时在经营普林斯顿的麦卡特剧院。他说，你想演戏吗？我说，当然。我当时是带薪的，我拿着长矛，我当时，你知道，在乔治·萧伯纳的《圣女贞德》里。但我演了这部戏，我简直不敢相信能和所有这些玩得这么开心的成年人在一起。他们坐在那里谈论上帝、爱和
story about, you know, child acting is dangerous. So a lot of the people that we came up with are dead, you know? I mean, And there's not a bunch of them that have, that are, that are still making a living. I mean, I, I don't say that to brag. I'm just, I'm so, I'm so proud of, of us, of, of anyone that can somehow navigate that, that transition from kid to young adult to, because it's so fickle and it's, it's not about who's good. It's just who can kind of stay like kind of semi-cool to hire. I don't mean to sound like a cynic, but you know, oftentimes it doesn't have anything to do with talent, I think.
剑术，你知道，所有这些，他们比我父母玩得开心多了。我是说，他们似乎是，我喜欢看这些人在排练。所以戏结束后，我从一个朋友那里听说纽约有一些公开试镜。我就开始和另一个孩子坐火车去纽约，去参加一些大型试镜。其中一个是《探索者》。你独自坐火车去纽约时多大？13岁。哇。
Well, it has to do with, I don't think it has to do with talent. It does have to do with a little bit of your DNA, who brought you up, your ability to handle failure, your ability to grow from failure. You know, I saw, I talked to Martha Plimpton the other day on the phone and she's just grown up to be such a remarkable human being. But if you don't do the stuff on the inside, your talent dies, you know, or it just gets, it gets beaten up. My first, my mom, I didn't have a winter sport. My mom didn't get home from work till seven, so she needed me to do, you know, I needed to be doing something in the winter.
是的。这太疯狂了。是的。很多，我应该说，我很多朋友的父母不让他们在我家过夜，因为他们认为我母亲太宽容了。等等，她是吗？她是吗？哦，是的。我是说，我去了纽约，但我是说，我16岁时独自去了欧洲，坐了欧铁，你知道，在夏天。是的。
So she signed me up for an acting class at the Paul Robeson Center for Performing Arts in Princeton, New Jersey. And I went to this class and they had a guest speaker come who did like a little improv thing. And I really, I was a giant ham as a kid. And after class, he came up to me in the parking lot and he said, would you like to be, he was running the MacArthur Theater in Princeton. And he said, would you like to be in a play? I was like, sure. And I was done was pay and I carried a spear and I was, you know, in George Bernard Shaw's St. Joan. But I did this play and I just couldn't believe being around all these adults who are having so much fun. They were sitting there talking about God and love and
是的。她非常重视独立。而且我认为如果她有另一个孩子，我可能在18岁时就进了戒毒所或死了。但出于某种原因，这很适合我。我真的很喜欢我的独立。好吧，你很幸运能在这么小的年纪找到给你带来快乐的事情，我认为这是成功的关键，你知道？是的。再次，不寻常。没多少人能得到那个。所以《探索者》是第一部，你的第一部电影，是吗？第一份大工作，是的。
sword fighting and, you know, all this, they were having so much more fun than my parents were. I mean, they seem to be, I loved watching these people in rehearsal. And so after the play was over, I heard through a friend of mine about some open casting calls in New York. And I just started riding the train into New York with this other kid and going on to some of the big casting calls. And one of them was Explorers. How old were you when you were just let go to go on your own on a train into New York? 13. Wow.
是的。那是谁？和瑞凡·菲尼克斯一起，乔·丹特导演。是的。哇。是的，那是瑞凡·菲尼克斯。《死亡诗社》是那种让你进入另一个类别的作品吗？你的意思是打破，不是像杀了我，而是像，是的。不，不。
Yeah. That's pretty crazy. Yeah. A lot of, I should say a lot of my friends, parents wouldn't let them sleep over at my house because they thought my mother was too lenient. Wait, was she? Was she? Oh, yeah. I mean, I went to New York, but I mean, I went to Europe by myself and rode the Uriel when I was 16, you know, in the summer. Yeah.
就像打破你的，就像你现在进入了这个行业。是的，绝对。那部电影的成功给了我一份职业。是的，太棒了。那是一部伟大的电影。所以谈谈为什么你不是，你知道，一个吸毒者，抢劫酒铺，做所有那些事情，尽管你是在，你知道，一种宽容的家庭中长大的，听起来，以一种好的方式。你被给予了空间，就像你被信任，直到你给妈妈一个不信任的理由，而你最终还好。现在，你能给自己一些功劳吗，你只是带着一个，带着一个，带着一个好的头脑
Yeah. She put a high value on independence. And I think if she'd had a different kid, I would have been in drug rehab or dead by 18. But for some reason it suited me. I really liked my independence. Well, you were lucky enough to find the thing that brought you joy at such a young age, which I think is key to success, you know? Yeah. Again, unusual. Not a lot of people get that. So Explorers is the first, your first film, is that it? First big gig, yeah.
感谢上帝。我只是觉得这是一种舞蹈，不是吗？你知道，我认为我们很多人如果父母不对，可能会处于非常糟糕的境地。嗯。是的。当你问我那个问题时，我脑海中闪过的是我想到了我的长女，玛雅，她在演戏，她现在在《怪奇物语》里。哦，酷。
Yeah. And who, that was it? With River Phoenix, directed by Joe Dante. Yeah. Wow. Yeah, it was River Phoenix. Is Dead Poets the thing that kind of broke you like into another category? You mean broke, like, not like killed me, but like, yeah. No, no.
等等，你女儿在《怪奇物语》里？是的。她是哪一个？她演罗宾。快去看。你在开玩笑吧。不，伙计。我根本不知道那是你女儿。她在里面太棒了。肖恩，他没在跟你开玩笑，该死。接受吧。
Like broke your, like you broke into the business now. Yeah, definitely. The success of that movie gave me a career. Yeah, that's amazing. It's such a great film. So talk about why you're not, you know, a drug addict, robbing liquor stores and doing all that stuff, even though you were brought up in, you know, kind of a permissive house, it sounds like, in a good way. You were given rope to, like you were trusted till you gave your mom a reason not to, and you just ended up being okay. Now, can you take some credit yourself that you just kind of came out with a, with a, with a good head on your shoulders
这是一次诚实的采访吗，肖恩？那太酷了。我不知道。是的。好吧，所以她是，她是一个非凡的年轻女性，我做对了一些事情，也做错了一些事情，她是谁，是那个能够区分，对吧，并理清自己生活的人。但你给了她那个，你给了她那个工具吗？我是说，好吧，答案可能是没有。我是说，她只是。
and thank God for that? I just think it's a dance, isn't it? You know, I think a lot of us with the wrong parents could be in a really bad situation. Mm-hmm. Yeah. What leaps to my mind when you asked me that is I think about my oldest, Maya, she's acting, she's on Stranger Things right now. Oh, cool.
我有点觉得她是天生的。是的，完全正确。是的，她，你阻止不了她。我记得她四岁时就非常确定她要成为一名艺术家。我是说，这只是她与水彩画相关联的方式。她给她看一张照片，她会改变它的构图。如果你给她读一首诗，她喜欢它，她就会背下来。我是说，她只是任何触及艺术的东西都是她的一部分。我没有，我给了她那个吗？我是说，这里有一个关于为什么这是一个舞蹈的例子，我们当时过得很艰难。我希望她不
And wait, your daughter's on Stranger Things? Yeah. Which one is she? She plays Robin. Get on it. You got to be kidding me. No, man. I had no idea that was your daughter. She's fantastic. Sean, he's not kidding you for fuck's sake. Just take it.
介意我这么说，她正处于青春期早期，我只是决定，好吧，我们需要花点时间在一起。我说，我有一周的假期，这其实有点好笑。我实际上在日历上写着电影在3月23日左右开始，但我记错了。它是30号开始的。所以我以为我要离开城里，突然间我像，天哪，我有一整周没事可做。我去找她，我说，听着，我知道你和我在一起过得很艰难，我让你心烦意乱等等。但我认为答案是让我们走吧。我想和你待一周。就像我有一周没事可做，我和你妈妈谈过了
Is this an honest interview, Sean? That's so cool. I didn't know that. Yeah. Well, so she's, she's a remarkable young woman and I did some things right and I did some things wrong and who she is is the person who is able to differentiate, right, and make sense out of her own life and. But did you give her that, did you give her that tool? I mean, well, the answer is probably is no. I mean, she's just.
我要带你逃学，我们只是要在一起待一周。我说，我会带你去任何你想去的地方。哇。我确信她会说巴黎什么的。你知道，我不知道。首先，我对“我要带你逃学”的反应是什么？我们要在一起待一周。我不认为她喜欢和我待一周，但她喜欢逃学。所以它是，但她说，她说她想去看看雅园，这完全震惊了
I kind of think she was born with it. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, she's, you weren't going to stop her. I remember her at four years old being pretty sure that she was going to be an artist. I mean, it was just the way she related to water coloring. She showed her a photograph and she would change the composition of it. And if you read her a poem and she liked it, she would memorize it. I mean, she just anything that touched the arts was a part of her. And I didn't, did I give her that? I mean, here's an example for you about why it's a dance is we were having a hard time. I hope she doesn't
我。我当时想，你为什么想去雅园？她说，我不知道，但她一直在YouTube上看猫王的视频，你知道，她只是爱他。所以我带她去了雅园，我们走进太阳录音室，她说，爸爸，看，她给我看她的手臂，她手臂上所有的汗毛都竖起来了，你知道，就像那种你起鸡皮疙瘩的事情。是的。她说，你感觉到了吗？你感觉到这个房间了吗？我记得当时想，我不知道那是这个房间还是她。就像房间是神奇的，但你必须有一种意识
mind me saying this and she's in her early adolescence and I just decided, all right, we need to spend some time together. And I said, I had a, I had a week off and it was actually kind of funny. I actually wrote in the calendar that a movie was starting like on the 23rd of March and I was just wrong. It was starting the 30th. So I thought I was supposed to leave town and all of a sudden I was like, geez, I have a whole week with nothing to do. And I went to her and I said, listen, I know you're having a hard time with me and I'm getting on your nerves and everything. But I think the answer is let's go. I want to spend a week with you. Like I've got nothing to do for a week and I talked to your mom
关于为什么它对你的汗毛来说是神奇的。就像她理解太阳录音室意味着什么，她关心它，并对它感兴趣。她理解山姆·菲利普斯在做什么。而且是的，她理解很多，因为我谈论过它，但你，我也谈论达拉斯牛仔队，她不在乎那个。你知道，所以它是，你知道，这些孩子就是他们自己，他们受到我们的影响。是的。是的。现在是赞助商时间。现在回到节目。我想回到你刚开始的时候，因为一个问题跳进我的脑海，关于
and I'm going to take you out of school and we're just going to go be together for a week. And I said, I'll take you anywhere you want to go. Wow. And I was sure she'd say Paris or something. You know, I didn't know. First of all, what was the reaction to where I'm going to take you out of school? We're going to spend a week together. I don't think she liked spending a week with me, but she liked getting out of school. So it was, but she said, she said she wanted to go see Graceland, which completely shocked
低谷期。就像，你知道，当你刚开始做演员时，你说你演了这部戏，它进展顺利，那种感觉真是太棒了，令人兴奋，和所有那些成年人在一起。然后我想在人们的心目中，像你这样成功的人，其他人会想，哦，它只是滚雪球，太棒了，我从未停止工作。但演员总是有低谷期，尤其是当你刚开始，你更年轻的时候。你是怎么度过那些难关的？你怀疑过自己吗？你是怎么度过那种怀疑的？你有没有过，天哪，我找不到工作。也许这行不通。也许我选错了。你知道，我经常这么说，人们认为
me. I was like, why do you want to go to Graceland? She's like, I don't know, but she'd been watching Elvis videos on YouTube, you know, and she just loved him. And so I took her to Graceland and we walked into Sun Studios and she said, dad, look, and she showed me her arm and all the hair on her arm was standing up, you know, like that thing where you get shivers. Yeah. And she's like, do you feel it? Do you feel this room? And I remember thinking, I don't know if that's this room or her. Like the room is magical, but you have to have an awareness
我在开玩笑，我想这是一种恭维什么的，但我确实有三次确定自己完蛋了。你知道，我生命中有三个不同的阶段，我当时想，哦，哇，结束了。就像，我不知道它会结束，因为当你，当你年轻时获得成功，它会以一种消极的方式劫持你的大脑，那就是你有点认为，哦，世界站在我这边。你知道，就像，哦，我做到了。我在18岁时演了《死亡诗社》。就像，那是我的突破。现在我是一个成功的人了。然后突然四年过去了，你拍了其他六部电影，它们都失败了。然后你想试镜一些热门
of why it's magical for your hair. Like she understood what Sun Studios meant and she was and she cared about it and was interested in it. She understood what Sam Phillips is up to. And yeah, she understood a lot of that because I talked about it, but you, I talk about the Dallas Cowboys too and she doesn't care about that. You know, so it's, you know, these kids are who they are and they're influenced by us. Yeah. Yeah. And now a word from her sponsor. And now back to the show. I want to go back to when you were starting out because a question jumped in my head about
电影，没人想让你试镜，因为他们听说过你，他们知道他们不喜欢你。你知道，还有所有这些24岁的刚大学毕业的人，现在他们正在寻找自己。他们走出，你知道，他们刚从这个戏剧项目毕业，每个人都对他们感到非常兴奋。对。他们像，不，我们不想要那个《死亡诗社》里的孩子。我看了那个糟糕的《神秘约会》。他太烂了。我记得，我记得无意中听到某个电影高管像，就像，我在洗手间，那是一个总裁，派拉蒙什么的。他说，你知道，美国为伊桑·霍克投了票，他不是电影明星。
dry spells. Like, you know, when you're starting out as an actor and you said you did this play and it goes, that was kind of amazing and thrilling being around all those adults. And then I think in people's minds, people who are as successful as you, other people think, oh, it's just snowballed and it was great and I never stopped working. But there are always dry spells for actors, especially when you're starting out and you're younger. How do you get through those? Did you doubt yourself? How did you get through that doubt? And were you ever like, God, I can't find a job. Maybe this isn't working. Maybe I chose the wrong thing. You know, I say this a lot and people think
他永远不会成功。我记得当时想，哦，天哪，那是在我拍的某部电影首映之后，我当时想，哦，天哪。然后你冲出来说，什么，他们，统计结果在哪里？不，我躲在里面。是的，当然。人们总是那样说话。他们喜欢把人写死。你知道，他们要么在捧你，要么在拆你。你正处于其中一个过程中。我有三次不同的经历，我真的很害怕。因为我爱它。我喜欢做它。而且我认为笑话是，它是你如何处理那些时刻，因为我们都在不断被要求过渡，你知道，即使，你知道，现在我的胡子变
I'm kidding when I say it, which I guess is a compliment or something, but I've definitely was certain I was washed up at three different times. You know, there were three different chapters of my life where I was like, oh, wow, it's over. Like, I didn't, I didn't know it was going to end because when you, when you have success young, it hijacks your brain in a kind of negative way, which is that you kind of think, oh, the world's on my side. You know, like, oh, I got this. I was in dead poet society when I was 18. Like, that's my break. Now I'm a made man. And then all of a sudden four years go by and you do six other movies and they're all failures. And then you want to audition for some happening
灰了，你知道，我必须作为演员过渡。我必须成为一个不同的演员。如果你试图保持你10年前的样子，你试图把自己粘在福尔马林里，因为那时人们喜欢你，你就死了。你必须改变，而且我认为你必须愿意放手一切。是的，如果你保持在同一个位置，你最终会不适合这个角色。如果你保持在同一个位置，而且伊桑，你，那么你是在哪一年开始Malaparte，你的剧团的？我在九十年代初。九十年代初。九十一年。那是在哪里，伊桑？那是剧团，就在，你知道，那是
movie and nobody even wants to let you audition because they've heard of you and they know they don't like you. You know, there's all these other 24 year olds that are just graduating college and now they're finding themselves. They're coming out of the, you know, they're just graduated from this drama program and everybody's really excited about them. Right. And they're like, no, we don't want that kid from dead poet society. I saw that terrible mystery date. He's awful. I remember, I remember overhearing some film exec like, like, like it was, I was in the bathroom and it was like a president, a paramount or something. And he was like, you know, America cast its vote for Ethan Hawke and he's not a movie star.
《死亡诗社》几年后，我从大学退学了。什么城市，但它在什么城市？纽约市。我拿了一些我赚的钱，在42街租了一个剧院，我有很多才华横溢的朋友，乔什·查尔斯，罗伯特·肖恩·伦纳德，乔纳森·马克·舍曼，史蒂夫·茨恩，一群不同的年轻艺术家男女，我们只是决定致力于制作年轻人的作品，你知道，我们自己这一代的作品，我们上演了这些小戏。它，它是一个，它是一个真正的轰动，我可以告诉你，作为一个1990年从多伦多搬到纽约的演员，我不认识任何人，这非常令人生畏
He'll never make it. And I remember going, oh my, it was that after a premiere of some movie I did, I was like, oh my God. And you come rushing out and go, what, what did they, where's the tallies? No, I hid inside there. Yeah, of course. People talk like that all the time. They love to write people off. You know, they're either building you up or tearing you down. You're either in the process of one of them. And I've had three different times where I really was scared. And because I love it. I love doing it. And I think the joke is that it's how you handle those moments when, because we're all constantly being asked to transition, you know, even, you know, now my beard's going
因为你们有那个。我认识Naked Angels里的一些人，你们有点像Naked Angels的答案，你们就像下一代，你们有所有这些很棒的家伙，做所有这些令人惊叹的事情。但我当时在想，那一定给了你相当多的，我本来想说喘息，但至少是一些你可以用来把你的心思从所有关于成为电影明星的政治和废话中移开，实际上只是专注于做你自己的事情。那是，那有什么真实性吗？你知道，杰森，我想知道你会，当我们谈论作为年轻演员生存时，实际上跳进我脑海的是我的朋友。我有非常好的
gray and, you know, I have to transition as an actor. I have to become a different actor. And if you try to stay the same person you were 10 years ago, you try to stick yourself in formaldehyde because people liked you then, you just die. You have to change and you have to be willing to let it all go, I think. Yeah, you end up being wrong for the part if you keep, if you stay in the same spot. If you stay in the same spot and how much, how much Ethan did you, so what year was it that you started Malaparte, your theater company? I was in the early nineties. Early nineties. Ninety-one. And where is that, Ethan? It was the theater company right after, you know, it was a couple
朋友。是的，乔什，乔什是一个很好的选择。这家伙真是个好人吗？向乔什问好。他真是个，但当，当你有好朋友对你说，你听起来真的很自大。是的。哦，你，你知道，你和你的经纪人混得太久了。你听起来像是在接受采访，而且你有你钦佩他们思考艺术方式的朋友，或者他们，我认为你的朋友可以救你的命。而且如果你没有合适的朋友，我知道就像有时我只是觉得我很幸运，关于朋友
of years after Dead Poets Society and I had dropped out of college and. What city, but what city is it in? New York City. I took some of the money I made and just rented a theater on 42nd Street and I had a lot of brilliant friends, Josh Charles, Robert Sean Leonard, Jonathan Mark Sherman, Steve Zahn, a bunch of different men and women that were young artists and we just decided to dedicate ourselves to producing young people's work, you know, the work of our own generation and we put on these little plays. It was, it was a, it was a real sensation and I can tell you as an actor who had moved to New York in 1990 from Toronto and I didn't know a single person, it was very intimidating
我交的朋友，他们是让我活下来并让我思考的人。阿门。而且，与行为方式你认为你不想要的方式的人擦肩而过。那也非常重要。是的。其实，你知道吗？我很高兴你这么说，杰森，你听起来真的很自大。哦，好吧，我们还在录吗？让我再来一次。不，但你知道，你知道，伊桑，我当时在想，你的一位朋友我认识，我从很久以前就认识很多那些家伙，但其中一个是乔什·汉密尔顿。我记得你记得他做了什么，因为我当时和米西·耶格住在一起，她是我的女朋友
because you guys had that. I knew some of the people in Naked Angels, you guys were kind of the answer to Naked Angels, you were like the next generation and you had all these great guys and doing all this amazing stuff. But I was thinking that must have given you quite a bit of, I was going to say respite, but at least something that you could get to sort of take your mind away from all the politics and the bullshit about being a movie star and actually just focus on doing your thing. Is that, is there any truth to that? You know, Jason, I wonder what you would, when we were talking about surviving being a young actor, what actually popped through my head is my friends. I had really good
当时他们做《我们的青春》。是的，和肯尼·摩根，和鲁法洛，乔什在里面太出色了，伙计。他太，太他妈好了。这让我想到了42街。是的，完全正确。我做米西在Malaparte和我演了一部戏。是的，没错。伊桑，你知道，我总是，我问很多来这个节目的人，如果你们在剧院里，如果你有任何伟大的，像悲剧，但有趣的剧院故事发生在你身上，比如有一天，我会分享，我有一个。我想我没和你们分享过。有一天只是这部戏，它叫《晚安奥斯卡》，在芝加哥。希望它会
friends. Yeah, Josh, Josh is a good choice for that. Is this such a good dude? Hello to Josh. He's such a, but when, when you have good friends who say to you, you sound really stuck up. Yeah. Oh, you've been, you know, you've been hanging out with your agent too long. You sound like you're on an interview and you have friends that you admire the way that they think about art or the way that they, I think that your friends can save your life. And if you don't have the right friends, I know like sometimes I've just feel so lucky that about the friends
去纽约。顺便说一下，我们肯定会在那里插入掌声。在戏的中间，在戏快结束的时候，我每晚都必须弹钢琴。这是故事的一部分。在第一排，有两个女孩，她们喝醉了，神志不清。当我弹奏时，这是戏里一个非常亲密，那种时刻。这些女孩，每次我只是像，我会弹奏像每10秒，她们就会喊，好样的！干得好！哇，看那个！就像观众席的其他部分完全安静，那些家伙会下来，他们试图上台。这简直是疯了。
that I made that they're the ones who kept me alive and kept me thinking. Amen to that. And also crossing paths with people that are behaving in a way that you recognize as a way that you don't want to be. That's also really important. Yeah. Actually, you know what? I'm glad you said that, Jason, you sound really stuck up. Oh, well, are we still rolling? Let me go again. No, but you know, you know, Ethan, I was thinking one of your friends that I knew, I know a lot of those guys from way back in the day, but one of the guys was Josh Hamilton. I remember what you remember when he did, because I was living with Missy Yeager was my girlfriend
是我创造了它们，是它们让我活了下来，让我保持思考。对此我深表赞同。此外，与那些行为方式让你意识到自己不想成为那样的人相遇，这也非常重要。是的。说真的，你知道吗？杰森，我很高兴你这么说，你听起来真的很自负。哦，好吧，我们还在录吗？让我重来一遍。不，但你知道吗，伊桑，我当时在想你认识的一个朋友，我从很久以前就认识他们中的很多人，其中一个是乔什·汉密尔顿。我记得，你还记得他演的那部戏吗？因为当时我和米西·耶格住在一起，她是我当时的女朋友
at the time when they did our youth. Yeah, with Kenny Morgan and with Ruffalo and Josh was so brilliant in that man. He was so, so fucking good. It just made me think of 42nd Street. Yeah, exactly. I did Missy did a play with me at Malaparte. Yes, that's right. Ethan, you know, I always, I ask a bunch of people who come on this show who are in the theater, if you have any great like tragic, but funny theater stories that happen to you like one night, I'll share, I have one. I don't think I've shared it with you guys. One night just to display, it's called Good Night Oscar in Chicago. Hopefully it's going
那时我们还年轻。是的，和肯尼·摩根还有鲁法洛一起，乔什在那部戏里真是太出色了。他真的，真的太棒了。这让我想起了《第42街》。是的，没错。我确实和米西在马拉帕特剧院合作过一部戏。是的，没错。伊桑，你知道，我总是问那些来参加这个节目的戏剧界人士，你有没有什么伟大的、悲剧但又有趣的戏剧故事，比如某天晚上发生的？我会分享一个，我想我还没跟你们讲过。有一天，就在这部戏里，它叫《晚安，奥斯卡》，在芝加哥上演。希望它能
to New York. And we're definitely inserting applause there by the way. And in the middle of the, in the middle of towards the end of the play, I have to play the piano every night. It's part of the story. And in the front row, there's two girls that were bombed, wasted out of their mind drunk. And while I'm playing, it's a really intimate like kind of moment in the play. And these girls, every time I just like, I would play like every 10 seconds, they'd go, right on! Way to go! Whoa, look at that! And it was like the rest of the audience was completely silent and the guys would come down and they tried to get on the stage. It was insanity.
去纽约。顺便说一下，我们肯定会在这里加入掌声。在戏演到一半，快结束的时候，我每天晚上都要弹钢琴。这是故事的一部分。在前排，有两个女孩喝得烂醉如泥。当我弹奏的时候，那是戏里一个非常亲密、感人的时刻。而这些女孩，每当我弹奏时，大概每隔10秒，她们就会喊：太棒了！干得好！哇，看那个！就像其他观众完全沉默一样，然后工作人员走下来，她们还试图爬上舞台。简直是疯了。
You were doing this play in a theater there in Chicago? Yes, I was. Yes. They were in the front row bombed way. It was so, it was so. I have a, I have a lot of good theater stories, man. I'm trying to, I'll go with the front row. I did a play called Hurley Burley with Josh Hamilton, Bobby Kennavali, Parker Posey. Oh, Bobby Kennavali. A lot of great people. But the director had this idea that my character was kind of a drug addict, a Nerdy Well type, that, that I should be on the stage passed out as the audience enters. Right. So at the 20, when the doors opened, I would have to be, and
你在芝加哥的剧院演那部戏吗？是的，我在演。是的。他们坐在前排，简直糟透了。真是，真是。伙计，我有很多很棒的戏剧故事。我试着，我选那个前排的故事吧。我演过一部叫《Hurlyburly》的戏，和乔什·汉密尔顿、鲍比·坎纳瓦尔、帕克·波西一起。哦，鲍比·坎纳瓦尔。有很多很棒的人。但导演有个想法，觉得我的角色是个瘾君子，那种书呆子，我应该在观众入场时就醉倒在舞台上。对。所以当20分钟，门打开时，我就必须，而且
I had to be in my underwear. It was supposed to be like hanging off my butt. And I'm just in my underwear, completely collapsed on a living room couch, right? It's just supposed to be bombed. And people would come and sit down and they would see me and it was like they were looking at their television. They would just talk about me. Like I wasn't there. Cause the first couple of rows I could just hear, you know, he's a really terrible person. I read this article in People Magazine where he said this stupid thing. He's really a jerk. He's a real misogynist. And I'm like, and I'm having a listen. And I can't like, I want to lift up my head and say, I'm right here. Okay. That hurts my
我得只穿内衣。内裤应该挂在屁股上。我就只穿着内衣，完全瘫在客厅的沙发上，对吧？就应该是那种烂醉如泥的样子。人们会进来坐下，看到我，就像在看电视一样。他们会谈论我，好像我不在那儿一样。因为前几排的人，我都能听到，你知道，他真是个糟糕透顶的人。我在《人物》杂志上读到这篇文章，他说了一些蠢话。他真是个混蛋。他真是个厌女症患者。我就想，我在听着呢。我不能，我想抬起头说，我就在这儿。好吧。那伤害了我的
feeling. And that's not true. Exactly. And, and it would be so painful. Ethan, Ethan, I want to just hijack for one minute interrupting, which is what I opened up with. I was just in town here getting a coffee with my middle son and my partner, my girl, we're getting coffee and this one comes by with her grandson and her son, whatever. She's standing, I'm going to say six feet from me. And she's looking at me, but talking to her son, she goes, I don't know. I can't really remember his name, but, but that's him. And I'm sitting having, and I'm stuck on a bench and she's six feet. And I just wanted to be like, Hey, you know, I'm alive.
感情。而且那不是真的。没错。而且，那会非常痛苦。伊森，伊森，我想打断一下，插播一分钟，就像我开头说的那样。我刚才在城里和我二儿子还有我伴侣，我女朋友，去喝咖啡。有个女人带着她孙子和儿子什么的走过来。她站着，离我大概六英尺远。她看着我，但却对她儿子说，我不知道。我不记得他的名字了，但，那就是他。我正坐着喝咖啡，被困在长椅上，她离我六英尺。我真想说，嘿，你知道吗，我还活着。
I can hear you. I'm breathing right here. Puppet property. Anyway, so you're on the, by the way, who directed that version of Hurley Burley? Scott Elliott. Of course. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
我能听见你说话。我就在这儿呼吸呢。木偶财产。总之，你当时在，顺便问一下，是谁导演了那个版本的《Hurlyburly》？斯科特·埃利奥特。当然。是啊。是啊。
And that's so funny. I had another time where my friend died on stage with me. How about that? Wait, what do you mean? Like literally? Like literally a great Canadian actor, Richard Easton, we had a scene in Tom Stoppard's coast of utopia where he had to scream at me, you know, I will not lend you any more money. He had this huge thing where his final line was, and that's my last word. No way. And as he, as he said it, his tongue fell out of his mouth the way like a brick would
那太搞笑了。我还有一次经历，我的朋友在舞台上和我一起时去世了。那次怎么样？等等，你是什么意思？真的吗？真的，一位伟大的加拿大演员，理查德·伊斯顿，我们在汤姆·斯托帕德的《乌托邦海岸》里有一场戏，他必须对我大喊，你知道，我不会再借给你钱了。他有一大段台词，最后一句是，那是我的最后一句话。不会吧。就在他，在他说话的时候，他的舌头从嘴里掉了出来，就像一块砖头
fall out. Like something was so wrong. Oh my God. What? And then he, then he hit the ground like, you know, I mean. Face first. Face first. And, and I was so frozen. I could, I'm still, and I know, I literally just went through my stomach. Yeah.
掉出来一样。好像出了什么大问题。天哪。什么？然后他，然后他倒在地上，你知道，我的意思是。脸朝下。脸朝下。而且，我当时僵住了。我能，我仍然，我知道，我当时真的感到胃里一阵翻腾。是啊。
The audience thought that that was part of the play, right? Because it kind of seemed, my final word and then he croaks and I'm standing there and I don't know what to, I'm looking at the audience and they're all laughing. And I just, my brain just went to the dark side. I was like, he's dead. He's, I mean, that guy, that guy is dead. My friend Richard is dead. And I don't know what to do. And Martha Plimpton was in the wings and she came out and she was so ballsy. She came out and she was just like, is there a doctor in the house? Is there a doctor in the house? And then some dude in the third row was like, I'm a doctor and
观众以为那是戏的一部分，对吧？因为看起来确实像，我的最后一句话，然后他挂了，我站在那儿，不知道该怎么办。我看着观众，他们都在笑。我的大脑直接进入了黑暗面。我在想，他死了。他，我的意思是，那个人，那个人死了。我的朋友理查德死了。我不知道该怎么办。玛莎·普林顿当时在侧台，她走了出来，她真是太勇敢了。她走出来说，这儿有医生吗？这儿有医生吗？然后第三排有个家伙说，我是医生，而且
the rest of the audience is still laughing. Pediatrist, but I'm here. No, he was, and then the prop guy came out and they did, what do you call it? CPR. They did CPR on him. And so he was dead for seven minutes and they revived him at center stage, Lincoln Center. No way. Two story. Big applause.
剩下的观众还在笑。足科医生，但我在这儿。不，他是，然后道具师出来了，他们做了，你叫它什么？心肺复苏。他们对他做了心肺复苏。所以他死了七分钟，他们在林肯中心舞台中央把他救活了。不会吧。太离谱了。大声鼓掌。
No, the audience had been evacuated. There was no applause for life. That's a waste. Yeah. Wow. I'm glad we were laughing because it has a good outcome. Yeah. He survived and he actually returned to the show about two months later. Wow. What was it?
不，观众已经被疏散了。没有为生命鼓掌。那太浪费了。是啊。哇。我很高兴我们当时在笑，因为结果很好。是啊。他活了下来，而且大约两个月后真的回到了剧组。哇。是什么？
A heart attack or something? Yeah. He had a full blown heart attack right there at center stage. Wow. Hey, Ethan, I've got a question for you. Something that is, I would assume is unique to young, young actors that become adults. Something that I sort of battle with or struggle with, but I remember it being a challenge. I wonder if you had the same thing. When you start training yourself to be convincing as another person at a time when you're still trying to figure out who you are or who you're going to become, right? As a child, you know, we
心脏病发作还是什么的？是啊。他在舞台中央突发了严重的心脏病。哇。嘿，伊森，我有个问题想问你。有些事情，我认为是年轻演员成为成年人后所独有的。我有点纠结或挣扎，但我记得那是个挑战。我想知道你是否有同样的经历。当你开始训练自己去扮演另一个人，而你还在试图弄清楚自己是谁，或者将来会成为谁时，对吧？作为一个孩子，你知道，我们
don't really figure out who we're going to be like to what, 16, 17, something, whatever the hell it is. So you're trying on all these different roles and really trying to be believable. And so that's causing you to really try to find that place inside of you that's kind of like that character. So it started to develop for me sort of like a manageable form of schizophrenia, right? Like a monetizable version of schizophrenia. But it sort of confused my path to identity and who I really was when I wake up in the morning or go to bed at night. Did you ever
直到16、17岁左右才真正弄清楚自己会成为什么样的人，不管那是什么。所以你在尝试所有这些不同的角色，并真正试图变得可信。这导致你真的试图找到内心深处那种像那个角色的地方。所以它开始为我发展出一种可控的精神分裂症，对吧？就像一种可货币化的精神分裂症版本。但这确实混淆了我对身份的认知，以及我早上醒来或晚上睡觉时我到底是谁。你有没有
deal with any of that starting as young as I did, training yourself to be somebody other than who you were organically becoming? Absolutely. I mean, you know, I mean, I had that, I mean, for example, when I was doing dead poet society, my character is extremely shy, right? He's extremely, and so you're accessing the part of yourself that is really shy, right? Like, well, what am I like when I'm really shy? And you start, it's almost like, oh, it sounds really corny to say, but you know, you hear those Buddhist guys say, just if you just make yourself smile for half an hour, you
处理过这些，像我一样从那么小就开始，训练自己成为一个与你自然成长过程不同的人？绝对有。我的意思是，你知道，我的意思是，例如，当我拍摄《死亡诗社》时，我的角色非常害羞，对吧？他非常害羞，所以你是在接触你自己内心真正害羞的那部分，对吧？就像，好吧，我真正害羞的时候是什么样的？你开始，这几乎就像，哦，说出来听起来很老套，但你知道，你听那些佛教徒说，如果你只是让自己微笑半小时，你
actually are in a good mood. And it does work. You can kind of hardwire your brain. Well, you can hardwire your brain for a lot of different things. And if you're doing a daily meditation on why a human being might hate themselves and not feel like what their words are worth anything, and you're accessing that part of yourself. Yes, you know, you're more than that. But it's kind of like you're wiring your brain to highlight that part of you. And I really struggled with that when that movie was over. And this has been an ongoing theme of my life of trying. I think actors spend a lot of time inviting, you know, how to get into character, right? You hear people say that all the time and see spent all this energy inviting depression,
实际上就会心情变好。这确实有效。你可以某种程度上重塑你的大脑。好吧，你可以为很多不同的事情重塑你的大脑。如果你每天都在冥想为什么一个人可能会讨厌自己，觉得自己的话一文不值，而你正在接触你自己的那一部分。是的，你知道，你不仅仅是那样。但这有点像你在重塑大脑以突出你自己的那一部分。那部电影结束后，我真的为此挣扎过。这一直是我生活中的一个持续主题，试图。我认为演员花了很多时间去邀请，你知道，如何进入角色，对吧？你一直听到人们这么说，而且花了很多精力去邀请抑郁、
anger, madness. It's most confusing with the darker emotions, right? You invite them in. But then what are you supposed to do with them once you've invited them into your psyche to play? And I found that I found that extremely difficult. And if you're talented, you have an aptitude for this. And it's actually an aptitude for insanity. You know, for sure. And I think the big lesson for young actors is if you're going to really think about character, you have to start to think about your own character. Well, it's, you know, it's so interesting because I'm really I'm obsessed with the black phone. I thought it was such a great movie. And I'll watch it again, like it's
愤怒、疯狂。这在处理黑暗情绪时最令人困惑，对吧？你邀请它们进来。但一旦你把它们邀请进你的心理去表演，你该拿它们怎么办呢？我发现这极其困难。如果你有天赋，你就有这种倾向。这实际上是一种疯狂的倾向。你知道，肯定的。我认为对年轻演员来说，最大的教训是，如果你真的要考虑角色，你必须开始考虑你自己的性格。好吧，你知道，这太有趣了，因为我真的，我沉迷于《黑色电话》。我觉得那是一部很棒的电影。我会再看一遍，就像
one of those movies I'll watch again and again, where you you actually I didn't know anything about it. And as I'm watching the movie, you're playing this crazy kidnapping silence of the lambs kind of guy. And I didn't think you I didn't think the character would be as dark as it is. I mean, you actually kill children. Yeah, like you kill them. And I was like, how in the world do you find this person? Like, how in the world did you find out how to play that guy? Because it was scary as shit. Maybe you don't want to know, Sean. Okay, maybe maybe just ask the wrong question guy. Maybe he's fucked with the wrong guy. And she drop your mic and pack your shit, Sean. Start running out. Where do you live?
那些我会一遍又一遍看的电影之一，你实际上，我对此一无所知。当我在看电影时，你扮演这个疯狂的绑架者，那种《沉默的羔羊》里的家伙。我没想到你，我没想到这个角色会这么黑暗。我的意思是，你真的杀了孩子。是啊，就像你杀了他们。我就想，你到底是怎么找到这个人的？我的意思是，你到底是怎么发现如何扮演那个家伙的？因为那真是太可怕了。也许你不想知道，肖恩。好吧，也许，也许只是问错了人。也许他惹错了人。放下麦克风，收拾好你的东西，肖恩。开始跑吧。你住哪儿？
I want to come over. It was really scary. No, you know, I, I don't really know how to answer that question, except that I feel as I get older, that acting at its best is a kind of shamanistic process. And that might sound pretentious or whatever. But it is you as a dude, like if everybody's sitting around the campfire, you like get up and you tell a story and you do a dance and you it's and you're kind of inviting these other spirits to be a part of the story in some way. It's you, you, you are a shaman that is kind of part of the job. And learning to invite different emotions in and letting them flow in and out makes a good storyteller. It's you have to know who you are. And I'm lucky what I did
我想过去。那真的很可怕。不，你知道，我真的不知道怎么回答那个问题，除了我觉得随着年龄增长，表演在最好的状态下是一种萨满式的过程。这听起来可能很自命不凡什么的。但这就是你作为一个男人，就像如果每个人都坐在篝火旁，你站起来讲个故事，跳个舞，你，而且你某种程度上是在邀请这些其他的灵魂以某种方式成为故事的一部分。这是你，你，你是一个萨满，这是工作的一部分。学会邀请不同的情绪进来，让它们流进流出，才能成为一个好的讲故事的人。你必须知道你是谁。我很幸运，我所做的
on that job, for example, is I just every day I get home from work, I would just go on a walk with my kids because the dad, the dad gene in me is way more powerful than the actor gene in me. Yeah, you know, like, and it, I know who I am in relationship to them very well. I'm their father. That's all that matters. And are we eating? Are we learning to tell the truth? Are we taking care of one another? All those really simple but now things it's kind of like a grounding wire for me. But I don't really know how to answer it. You know, it's funny. It occurs to me you touched on it that, you know, that your character in Dead Poets Society was, you know, very sort of shy. And then you had said earlier when
在那份工作中，例如，我只是每天下班回家，就会和我的孩子们去散步，因为我体内的父亲基因比演员基因强大得多。是啊，你知道，而且，我非常清楚我与他们的关系。我是他们的父亲。这才是最重要的。我们在吃饭吗？我们在学习说真话吗？我们在照顾彼此吗？所有这些非常简单但现在看来很重要的事情，对我来说就像一条接地线。但我真的不知道怎么回答。你知道，这很有趣。我突然想到你提到了，你知道，你在《死亡诗社》中的角色，你知道，非常害羞。然后你之前说过，
you were, when you first started taking acting part of this theater, when you were a kid in Princeton, that they, that you were actually quite a ham and whatever. And I've always thought of you, I don't know you again, but I've always thought of you as kind of a shy guy. And I wonder if it's because of that impression. I just went around to all three of you guys. And I was thinking like, Sean, the character that you first like sort of introduced you to the world was your character on Will and Grace, who was very kind of crazy and all over the place. And Jason, you were kind of a wise ass. I knew you from, it's your move before we became friends when you did that. And you were like this wise ass.
当你刚开始在普林斯顿当孩子时参加戏剧表演，他们，你实际上是个很爱表现的人什么的。我一直认为你，我又不认识你，但我一直认为你是个害羞的人。我想知道是不是因为那个印象。我刚才绕着你们三个人转了一圈。我在想，肖恩，那个最初把你介绍给世界的角色是你在《威尔和格蕾丝》中的角色，他非常疯狂，到处都是。而杰森，你有点像个自作聪明的人。我在我们成为朋友之前就知道你，在你做那个的时候。你就像个自作聪明的人。
And that's maybe how you're introduced to the world is that thing. And a lot of people knew me just from the first thing they knew me for was probably A Rest of the Velma, where I played this insane magician who was over the top and illusionist. Thank you. And you know, like that, that you get kind of, and I was thinking you get typecast, not just for work for life. Yeah. Well, I always say that, you know, the thing about being an actor that nobody tells you is it robs you of the ability to make a first impression anymore. So interesting. You meet people and they have a first impression. And for some people, I don't, there was a whole
那可能就是你被介绍给世界的方式。很多人认识我只是因为他们认识我的第一件事，可能是《现实咬人》，我在里面扮演了一个疯狂的魔术师，非常夸张，是个幻觉师。谢谢。你知道，就像，你被定型了，不仅仅是工作，而是生活。是啊。好吧，我总是说，你知道，作为演员没人告诉你的事情是，它剥夺了你给人留下第一印象的能力。太有趣了。你遇见人们，他们有第一印象。对于有些人，我不，有一个整体
group of people when I was younger that hated me because they hated the guy from reality brights. You know, they think Troy's a jerk. I don't like you. You think you're so cool. You know, and you're like, what man? I'm like, dude, I played the character, you guys. When you relax, like, I didn't steal Winona from Ben Stiller. Like, you don't have to be mad at me. Dude, that's funny. But Will Ferrell used to do that. If you go with Will, people would be like, Hank, Hank, and they attack him and you end up being security for Will because people are like, we're going to party and drink and run down the street naked now. Right? He's like, no, man, I've got fucking four kids. What are you doing?
当我年轻时，有一群人讨厌我，因为他们讨厌《现实咬人》里的那个家伙。你知道，他们认为特洛伊是个混蛋。我不喜欢你。你以为你很酷。你知道，你会想，怎么了伙计？我就像，老兄，我只是扮演那个角色，你们这些家伙。当你放松时，就像，我没有从本·斯蒂勒那里偷走薇诺娜。就像，你不必对我生气。老兄，那太搞笑了。但威尔·法瑞尔过去常那样。如果你和威尔在一起，人们会说，汉克，汉克，他们攻击他，你最终成了威尔的保镖，因为人们就像，我们要去派对，喝酒，现在光着身子跑在街上。对吧？他说，不，伙计，我有四个孩子。你在干什么？
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, Ethan, talk about your, talk about your relationship with fame and success, I put in quotes, because, you know, in my opinion, you've hit the gold medal with success as far as longevity goes. Like that, to me, that's the tough thing to do. Like, you know, all you need nowadays is just a sex tape to get your head above the titles and to get a lot of money. So that's, you know, to get fame and money, it's, it's sex. So, yeah, anything else. Yeah, just mean, just some shots of me. Sorry, I was just talking to my assistant
我们马上回来。现在回到节目。嘿，伊森，谈谈你对名声和成功的关系，我加了引号，因为，你知道，在我看来，就长久性而言，你已经获得了成功的金牌。对我来说，那才是最难做到的。就像，你知道，如今你只需要一个性爱录像带就能出名并赚很多钱。所以那是，你知道，获得名声和金钱，那是，性。所以，是的，其他任何东西。是的，只是意味着，只是我的一些镜头。抱歉，我刚才在和我的助理说话
real quick. So you strike me as somebody who is completely fulfilled with, with what you do, the level that you do it. You've never seemed to be a person that has had a thirst for fame, fortune, recognition, celebrity. You're, you're, it seems that you've always been on a quest to be an actor that's working and also an actor that's respected. And not that that is, you know, a contrived agenda, but it is just a great result of the choices that you make. Is that something that you give a lot of thought to? Or is it just sort of, well, I just kind of get the roles that I get. And the perception is what it is. It is not something of my making
很快。所以你给我的印象是一个对自己所做的事情、所达到的水平完全满足的人。你从来不像是一个对名声、财富、认可、名人身份有渴望的人。你，你，似乎一直都在追求成为一个正在工作的演员，同时也是一个受人尊敬的演员。并不是说那是一个人为的议程，但这只是你所做选择的一个伟大结果。这是你经常思考的事情吗？还是说，好吧，我只是得到了我得到的角色。而看法就是那样。这不是我制造的
it's not a, it's not a recipe that I've, I've got my eye on and not something that you're, you're proactive at. Well, our life is how we spend it. And so I think I could easily say, oh yeah, it's no big deal. But no, I put a lot of thought. I'll give you an example when you were saying that I, did you guys see the new Elvis movie? No, yeah. I haven't seen it yet. It's funny because Elvis is interesting to me because you know how when Tarantino makes
这不是一个我盯着看的食谱，也不是你主动追求的东西。好吧，我们的生活就是我们如何度过它。所以我认为我可以很容易地说，哦，是的，没什么大不了的。但不，我思考了很多。我给你举个例子，当你那样说的时候，你们看过新的猫王电影吗？没有，是啊。我还没看过。这很有趣，因为猫王对我来说很有趣，因为你知道当昆汀制作
biopics, he changes the ending, you know, like, yeah, yeah. Well, I'd like to do an Elvis movie that ends right when the kernel, you know, when, when Sun Studios is exploding and Elvis is breaking, the kernel signs them up. They leave Sun Studios. He signs the biggest contract in music history with RCA. And I would make a strong case to be made that he died that day, you know, that, that, that when the object of your life becomes about succeeding versus what you are succeeding about, because if his goal in life was to make beautiful music, there is no doubt that he should have stayed with Sam Phillips. He, he loved African American music. He loved what Sam Phillips was doing there. All his success came from
传记片时，他会改变结局，你知道，就像，是啊，是啊。好吧，我想拍一部猫王电影，在桑尼唱片公司爆炸、猫王成名、上校签下他时结束。他们离开桑尼唱片公司。他与RCA签下了音乐史上最大的合同。我会强烈主张他那天就死了，你知道，当你的生活目标变成关于成功，而不是关于你正在成功的事情时，因为如果他的人生目标是创作美丽的音乐，毫无疑问他应该留在山姆·菲利普斯身边。他热爱非裔美国人的音乐。他热爱山姆·菲利普斯在那里所做的一切。他所有的成功都来自于
singing black music and he should have stayed there and helped other musicians. And I mean, it's easy. I'm not, I'm using him as an example, right? I'm not casting judgment on the dead. What I'm saying is like, I think the path to longevity, like this is what I said to Maya is like, she wants to be an actor. I'm like, okay, how do you feel if you're 63 and you're teaching, acting at a prep school in Seattle? She's like, Oh, that'd be amazing. Right. Okay. The second she says that it's all going to go fine. Yeah, right. It's, it's all going to go fine. And you have to, my point about the Elvis thing is if his goal was making music, yeah, he made the wrong decision. It doesn't matter what the price
唱黑人音乐，他应该留在那里帮助其他音乐家。我的意思是，这很容易。我不是，我只是把他作为一个例子，对吧？我不是在评判死者。我想说的是，我认为长久性的道路，就像我对玛雅说的那样，她想成为一名演员。我说，好吧，如果你63岁了，在西雅图的一所预科学校教表演，你感觉如何？她说，哦，那太棒了。对吧。好吧，她一说出那句话，一切都会好起来的。是啊，对吧。一切都会好起来的。你必须，我关于猫王那点的意思是，如果他的目标是创作音乐，是的，他做出了错误的决定。不管RCA的价签是多少，你知道，无论他在哪里，他都会是摇滚乐中最伟大的东西。他不明白他拥有球。他拥有天赋。山姆·菲利普斯拥有天赋。他们会改变音乐。音乐会改变，对吧？那会发生的。他本可以，他只是本末倒置了，你知道，所以我尝试在关于角色和类似事情的决策上做的是，如果你的重点在于它如何发展你作为一个人的能力，它如何发展你的艺术，它如何发展你的生活，那么有些事情，我知道，例如，我开玩笑说想拒绝纽曼·伍德沃德纪录片，但我知道那对我会有好处。
tag from RCA was, you know, he would have been the biggest thing in rock and roll, wherever he was. He didn't understand that he had the ball. He had the talent. Sam Phillips had the talent. They were going to change music. Music was going to change, right? That was going to happen. And he could have, he just put the car before the horse, you know, and so what I try to do with decision making about parts and things like that is if your focus is on how it develops you as a person, how it develops your art, how it develops your life, then there's things, I knew, like, for example, I was making a joke about wanting to say no about the Newman Woodward documentary, but I knew that that would be good for me.
对吧。我的意思是，这些人把他们的一生都奉献给了我试图奉献的那件事。他们在更高的水平上做了更长的时间。而我在这里。我接到那个电话时快50岁了，感觉就像，好吧，宇宙给了我一个小挑战。嘿，准备好了吗？你能做到吗？我知道，我不想做。就像，我没有成为纪录片制作人的欲望。那不是我的人生目标，但宇宙是，我不能掌控一切。它在向我发号施令。我知道，冥想这两个人尽可能长的时间可能会对我的生活产生好的影响。而且确实如此。
Right. I mean, these, these are people that dedicated their whole life to the same thing I've tried to dedicate mine to. They did it at a much higher level for a lot longer. And here I am. I was turning 50 when I got that phone call and it felt like, well, the universe has given me a little challenge. Like, Hey, ready? Can you do this? And I knew, I didn't want to do it. Like, I have no desire to be like a documentarian. That's not my goal in life, but the universe is, I'm not in charge of everything. It's dictating it to me. I knew that meditating on these two people for as long as it took would probably do good things to my life. And it definitely did.
所以如果我没听错的话，听起来你对那条路看起来是什么样子的有一个非常清晰的想法，那条路能满足你的，抱歉用这个词，你的，灵魂，在创造上、精神上，而且你只是他妈的说灵魂。我道歉。而且那在影响你的决定。而且看起来你可能也已经以这样一种方式生活，即你没有在生活中创造出与你遵循那种本能的能力相冲突的东西。换句话说，你没有生活中某种令人窒息的开销数字。就像，哦天哪，你知道，我的六栋房子和我的17辆车要求我不要，不要掉进杰森总是试图得到的每个人的
So if I'm hearing you right, it sounds like you've got a very clear idea about what, what the road looks like that fulfills your, sorry for the term, your, your soul creatively, spiritually, and you're letting you just fucking say soul. I apologize. And that's informing your decisions. And that it would also seem like you would probably and have probably lived your life in such a way where you're not creating things in your life that are at odds with your ability to follow that instinct. In other words, you don't have some choking overhead number in your life. Like, Oh my God, you know, my, my six houses and my, you know, my 17 cars mandate that I don't, don't fall for Jason's always trying to get to everybody's
开销数字，那决定了你必须在某部电影中扮演那个灵魂破碎的主角，那只会给你一大笔薪水，然后随之可能导致职业自杀。所以你没有为自己设置任何那些陷阱，尽管我相信你过着非常舒适的生活，你正在，你正在让你的，你的，你的其他东西决定你的职业选择。是的。是的。现在我们又回到了那种天性与教养，你知道，当你那样说的时候，就像我妈妈是一个反物质主义者。就像她，她怀疑任何在汽车、珠宝或任何外部财富积累展示上花费太多钱的人
overhead number that you're, that, you know, that, that, that dictates that you have to take that soul crushing starring role in something that just gives you a big paycheck and then consequently probably leads to career suicide. So you haven't set yourself up for any of those trappings, even though I'm sure you live a very comfortable life, you're, you're letting, you're letting your, your, your other stuff dictate your career choices. Yes. Yes. And now we're back to the like nature nurture, you know, as you say that, like my mom is an anti materialist. Like she's, she is suspect of anyone who spends too much money on an automobile or jewelry or anything, any exterior show of an accumulation of wealth
或地位，对吧？她对它过敏，并立即怀疑它。那是我成长的房子。所以如果我遇见了上校，你知道，如果我是猫王，就像我会，我的意思是，他是个骗子，对吧？是啊。你知道，而且，猫王生活中没有那个。我不知道为什么我谈论猫王这么多，但，但我的观点是，是的，我认为，你知道，我们都希望能够有一个体面的屋顶，并为我们孩子的健康买单。你知道，我们都想要那个。但如果你对中产阶级的审美不舒服，而你真的想要8000万双鞋子之类的东西，如果你不是天才，你就会有麻烦。
or status, right? She's, she's allergic to it and suspicious of it immediately. That's the house I was growing up in. So if I had met the colonel, you know, if I was Elvin, like I would, I mean, he's a shyster, right? Yeah. You know, and, and Elvis didn't have that in his life. I don't know why I'm talking about Elvis so much, but, but my point is, yes, I think that, you know, we all want to be able to have a decent roof and pay for our kids' health. You know, we all want that. But if you're not comfortable with like a middle class aesthetic and you really want 80 million pairs of shoes and stuff, you're going to get in trouble if you're not a genius.
是啊，肖恩。是啊。是啊，肖恩。嘿，肖恩，我买的每一双鞋，我都能工作。等等。我确实想，我确实想说，所以伊森，我是杰森，我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为它，你知道，如果你看看你过去30年制作的电影，在很多不同的类型中有很多不同的电影。大量的商业电影，以及。是啊。大量的商业，是啊。大量的商业，但也像，你知道，你制作了，首先
Yeah, Sean. Yeah. Yeah, Sean. Hey, Sean, for every pair I buy, I could work. Hang on. I do want to, I do want to say, so Ethan, I'm Jason, I'm glad you brought that up because it, you know, if you look at the movies that you've made, you've made over the last 30 years, a lot of different films in, in, in a lot of different genres. Tons of commercial movies, as well as. Yeah. Tons of commercial, yeah. Tons of commercial, but also like, you know, you made, first of
我想谈谈《千钧一发》。我爱，我觉得那是一部被严重低估的电影。那是一部伟大的电影，我可能看过三四次了。我就是喜欢那个，伙计。是什么，是什么吸引你去做那个？但我一直想谈谈那部电影。安德鲁·尼科尔写的，那是我读过的最好的剧本之一。我的意思是，如果，如果我们不是在谈论伟大的艺术，就像科幻小说真的打开了我的生活。就像我小时候读库尔特·冯内古特、托尔金、菲利普·K·迪克，你知道，这些东西让你的大脑挑战社会以及社会作为真理抛给你的东西。而《千钧一发》只是一个令人震惊的剧本。我很高兴你这么说，因为，你知道，当那部电影出来时，
all, I want to talk about Gattica. I love, I think a really underappreciated film. That is a great, and I've seen it probably three or four times. I just love that, man. What was, what drew you to that? But I've always wanted to talk about that movie. Andrew Nickel wrote, that was one of the best scripts I've ever read. I mean, if, if we're, if we weren't talking about great art, like sci-fi really opened up my life too. Like when I read Kurt Vonnegut as a kid, Tolkien, Philip K. Dick, you know, these things make your brain challenge society and what society throws at you as truth. And Gattica was just a staggering script. And I'm so happy that you say that because, you know, when that movie came out,
它是一个失败。但在过去的20年里，它找到了它的观众。我一直认为安德鲁·尼科尔是我遇到过的最好的作家之一。太好了。是啊。不，我在剧院看过它，我后来在各种地方看过。当你，当你，因为你如此沉浸在你喜欢做的一切事情中，戏剧、电影、写作，你做些什么来逃避它，如果你需要的话？我知道你喜欢音乐，对吧？你是个大音乐迷。体育，你会关注体育。你喜欢什么？我认为我生命中秘密的祝福之一，我只是一个超级粉丝。你知道，我的意思是，
it was a failure. But over the last 20 years, it's found its audience. And I've always thought Andrew Nickel is one of the, just one of the best writers I've ever come across. So, so good. Yeah. No, I saw it in the theater and I've seen it subsequent in all sorts of. When you, when you are, because you're so immersed in everything that you love to do, the theater, the film, writing, what do you do to escape it if you ever need to? I know you like music, right? You're a big music guy. Sports, you'll follow the sport. What do you like? I think one of the secret blessings of my life, I'm just a huge fan. You know, I mean,
我热爱音乐。我热爱电影。我认为我能够从事这么多不同类型的电影工作的原因是我实际上真的很喜欢它们。你知道我的意思吗？人们总是能看出你是否，哦，你知道，如果你是为了钱，他们闻得到，当你不喜欢你正在做的事情时，他们闻得到。所以音乐是我秘密的伟大激情，一遍又一遍地听唱片，寻找新的音乐。我不是，我对那种艺术没有天赋。就像我不擅长它。所以我可以只是极客一下，做一个粉丝，热爱他们所做的事情。你玩什么吗？是啊，我弹吉他弹得很烂。我最大的两个孩子，玛雅和莱冯，都是真正的音乐家
I love music. I love movies. The reason I've been able to work in so many different genres of movies I think is I actually really like them all. You know what I mean? People can always tell if you're, oh, you know, if you're a cash in and they smell, they smell it when you don't like what you're doing. And so music is my secret great passion, listening to records over and over again, finding new music. I'm not, I have no aptitude for that art. Like I'm not good at it. So I can just geek out and be a fan and love what they do. Do you ever play anything? Yeah, I play the guitar badly. Both my oldest two, Maya and Levon, are both actual musicians
而且他们已经超过我太多了，以至于现在在家里弹吉他都很尴尬，因为他们弹得太好了。但不，我喜欢它。你会花大价钱买票去看谁的演唱会？哇。除了猫王？除了，好吧，如果我能让猫王死而复生，那会非常好。有很多人，你知道，伊森·霍克说他想让猫王死而复生，给他建议如何
and they've lapped me so much that it's now embarrassing to play the guitar in my house because they play so well. But no, I love it. Who would you pay top dollar for a ticket to go see concert? Wow. Besides Elvis? Besides, well, if I could get Elvis back from the dead, that'd be really good. There's so many people, you know, Ethan Hawke says he wants to get Elvis back from the dead to give him advice on how to
处理上校。不，汉密尔顿·灯塔是来自，他是The Walkman的主唱，他为我刚做的纪录片《最后的电影明星》做了配乐。他简直太棒了。我强烈推荐人们买他的音乐。他只是被低估了，而且令人难以置信。天才。天才，天才的家伙。我觉得我们有很多相似之处，伊森就像更成功、更好奇、更具艺术倾向和天赋。别忘了帅。我。
deal with the Colonel. No, Hamilton Lighthouse is from the, he was the lead singer of The Walkman and he did the score for the last movie stars that Doc I just did. And he's just brilliant. I highly recommend people buy his music. He's just underrated and incredible. Brilliant. Brilliant, brilliant dude. I feel like we have a lot of similar, Ethan's like a lot more successful slash curious slash like artistically inclined and gifted. Don't forget handsome. Me.
比我更帅。他只是拥有所有这些，我知道这太神奇了。他就像一个更有趣的人。而且他可以演更年轻的角色。我就像一个比他有趣10倍的人，但不，我只是说这不重要。这不重要。我们不会深入讨论它。所以，所以，但是，但是然后你做，这是我想谈的另一件事。所以你做像《千钧一发》这样的事情，我不想过多地纠缠这一点，但我喜欢它。然后你制作这些《爱在》系列，这些与理查德·林克莱特合作的电影，你们似乎有这种惊人的、看似惊人的关系
Hands more handsome than me. He's just got all this, I know it's amazing. He's like a way more interesting. And he could play even younger. And I'm like a 10 times more interesting, but no, I'm just saying that it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. We're not going to get into it. So, so, but, but then you do, here's the other thing I want to talk about. So you do things like Gattica and I don't want to belabor this too much, but I love it. And then you make these link later, these movies with Richard Linklater, you guys have this amazing, seemingly amazing relationship with
和他以及朱莉·德尔佩。你们一起拍了多少部电影，你们也写了三部，三部。是啊。你们也写了。嗯。我的意思是，谈谈从与安德鲁·尼科尔合作制作《千钧一发》到制作这些电影的完全转变。然后你和丹泽尔以及安托万·福奎阿一起制作了《训练日》。我的意思是，这些是，你知道，你因为不同的类型而感到鞭打
him and with Julie Delpy. And how many of those films did you guys, which you also wrote three, three. Yeah. Which you also wrote. Mm hmm. I mean, talk about a complete shift from working with Andrew Nick on doing Gattica to doing these movies. And then you do training day with Denzel and Antoine Foucault. I mean, this is, these are, you know, you're getting whiplash for it with the different genres
在这里，但似乎都是你真正喜欢并且可以轻松做到的事情。好吧，我会，这当然不容易，但我，我不知道怎么回答，怎么谈论那个。那个写作的事情是，写作，告诉我写作的事情很难。不要告诉我写作的事情很容易。那不是就像盯着墙，试图填满空白页，你被所有可用的选项淹没了？你如何减少它，并达到你写作的水平？我认为对年轻演员来说写作非常重要，因为它让他们，你知道，那个
here, but seemingly all stuff that you're really into and can do with, with ease. Well, I would, it's certainly not easy, but I, I don't know how to answer, how to speak to that. That writing thing is that the writing, tell me the writing thing is hard. Don't tell me the writing thing is easy. Isn't that like just staring at a wall, trying to fill a blank page and just you're overwhelmed with all the options available to you? And how do you reduce that down and right at the level that you're writing? I think it's really important for young actors to write because it gets some, you know, that
我们一直在说的关于角色和关于你是谁的全部事情。如果你一直在解读别人的话，知道你自己的话是什么是非常有价值的。它不需要出版。它不需要，但只是，只是听到你自己声音的能力。而且我，我想我会回答你刚才说的。我成长过程中，我妈妈在厕所上方有这句名言，那就是，如果你在一种天赋上有所提高，上帝会给你更多。另一个是，要掌握一种手艺，你必须当三个学徒。我厕所上方有一个。上面写着，请保持整洁并擦拭座位。但我试图表达的观点是，对我来说，所有这些事情都相互促进。就像
whole thing we're saying about character and about who you are. And if you're constantly interpreting other people's words, it's extremely valuable to know what your words are. It doesn't need to be for publication. It doesn't need to be, but just, just the ability to hear your own voice. And I, I think we'll answer what you were saying. My mom had this quote above the toilet when I was growing up, which is, if you improve in one talent, God will give you more. And the other one was to, to master one craft, you have to apprentice three. I have one over the toilet. It says, please be neat and wipe the seat. But the point I'm trying to make is that for me, all these things fed each other. Like
如果你和丹泽尔·华盛顿在蒙特卡洛待了四个月，在很高的水平上与他一起工作，你不会忘记那个，对吧？你会把它带到你的下一份工作中。所以当林克莱特想让我做这个12年的项目时，我们要拍一部关于成长的短片，我将在12年里与这个年轻的孩子一起演戏，我可以带上我从与丹泽尔在片场学到的东西。他创造，他不等别人为他创造一个创造性的氛围来工作。他让它发生，对吧？而且，一旦你看到那是可能的，它就打开了大门，你知道，能够
if you're sitting in a Monte Carlo for four months with Denzel Washington, working with him at a very high level, you don't unsee that, right? And you bring that with you on your next job. So when Linkletter wants me to do this 12 year project, we're going to make a short film about growing up and I'm going to be acting with this young kid over 12 years, I can bring what I've learned from the time on set with Denzel. He creates, he doesn't wait for people to create a creative atmosphere for him to work. He makes it happen, right? And it's, and once you see that that's possible, it opens up doors, you know, getting to be
在排练室里和汤姆·斯托帕德在一起，看到他是如何痴迷于每一个辅音和元音，以及整个事情如何像诗一样运作，看到那个水平的写作，山姆·谢泼德能够和这些人在一起。如果你在注意，你会把它带到下一份工作中，你知道？而且我真的很感激，你知道，里克邀请朱莉和我与他一起写那些电影。而且，你们看过《年少轻狂》吧？我的意思是，能和我们这一代人一起工作真是太令人兴奋了，他没有模仿别人。他问了这个问题，比如我们这一代人是什么，你知道？我们在贡献什么？我们如何推动形式
in a rehearsal room with Tom Stoppard and getting to see like how he obsesses on every consonant and vowel and the way the whole thing works like a poem and seeing writing at that level, Sam Shepard getting to be around these people. If you're paying attention, you bring it with you on the next job, you know? And I was really grateful, you know, Rick invited Julie and I to write those movies with him. And, you know, you guys saw Days of Confused, right? I mean, it was so exciting to be working with somebody of our generation who wasn't imitating other people. He was asking this question like what is our generation, you know? What are we contributing? How can we push the forum
前进？所以，是的，你是过去发生的事情的学生，以了解他们是如何推动他们的时间段的，但不是为了模仿他们，而是为了在你自己的这一代人中存在。伙计，我他妈的太喜欢那个了。我是同样的坚定支持者。对我来说没什么。我总是谈论它在喜剧中，但我讨厌任何感觉太衍生出来的东西。我经常对这些家伙抱怨其他人，我觉得他们有点，我甚至不是指偷别人的段子。我的意思是，只是在做他们的事。偷他们的态度，是啊。偷他们的态度，这让我感到非常沮丧。我经常不得不被这些家伙劝阻，因为我对此太固执了
forward? And so, yeah, you're a student of what happened before to understand how they moved their time period, but not to imitate them, but to be present in your own generation. Dude, I fucking love that so much. I'm such a big proponent of the same. There's nothing for me. I always talk about it in comedy, but I hate anything that feels too derivative. I rail against often to these guys about other people who I feel like are kind of, not just I don't even mean stealing somebody's bit. I mean, just kind of doing their thing. Stealing their attitude, yeah. Stealing their attitude and it bums me out on such a profound level. And I often have to be talked off the ledge by these guys for being such a crank about
它。当他们靠这个赚钱时，这会给我带来身体上的痛苦。是啊，我也是，伙计。我也是。让我他妈的疯狂。我会把我的名单发给你。如果你看到我的，如果你，我为玛雅在《怪奇物语》中饰演罗宾感到自豪的事情之一是，它证明了这个观点，即你不必试图变得原创。如果你是你自己，你就会是原创的。停止模仿其他人。她把她自己和她所能提供的带给了这个角色。突然间，我以前在电影中没见过那个角色。这是一个独特的人。而且那是，当你看到一个喜剧演员、音乐家，任何人带上他们自己，你知道，那么他们就是在原创。是啊。
it. It causes me physical pain when they make money at it. Yeah, same here, man. Same here. Makes me fucking crazy. I'm gonna send you my list. If you see my, if you, one of the things I'm so proud of Maya about as Robin on Stranger Things is it's proof of this idea that you don't have to try to be original. If you are yourself, you will be original. Stop imitating everybody else. She brought herself and what she has to offer to this character. And all of a sudden I haven't seen that character in film before. It's a unique person. And that's, and when, when you see a comedian, a musician, anybody bring themselves, you know, then they are originating. Yeah.
而且这很鼓舞人心。太令人兴奋了。哦，伙计。我告诉你，伊森，非常感谢你的，你，我们占用了你太多的时间。谢谢。请继续保持原创。继续保持好奇。是啊。是啊。喜欢看你做你做的事情，伙计。能让你在这里真是太荣幸了。你非常，非常鼓舞人心。真的很鼓舞人心。我很高兴终于能和你说话并见到你。我不敢相信我们，我们的道路直到现在还没有更显著地交叉。我知道。我是你们的忠实粉丝，你们是我做这个节目的原因。而且我喜欢这样一个事实，你们是，你知道，关于成为惊喜嘉宾的事情是你们没有准备好的问题，当你做采访时，你可以感觉到
And it's inspiring. It's so exciting. Oh man. I tell you what, Ethan, thank you so much for your, you, we've taken up so much of your time. Thank you. Please keep staying original. Keep staying curious. Yeah. Yeah. Love watching you do what you do, man. It's such an honor to have you here. You're very, very inspiring. Really inspiring. I'm so glad to finally speak to you and meet you. I can't believe we, our paths haven't, haven't crossed more significantly till now. I know. I'm a big fan of you guys and you're why I did the show. And I love the fact that you guys are, you know, the thing about being the surprise guest is you guys don't have prepared questions and when will you do an interview and you can sense
采访者确切地想要你说什么。你还记得1998年，你告诉《滚石》杂志，记得，记得，再说一遍。对。对。对。对。是啊。不，我们只是，我们只是三个被困在电梯里的傻瓜，和你在一起，我们把你困了一个小时。而且，我们，我想我们所有人都理解当你所说的，你知道，这是关于友谊，我们很幸运能做这个，因为我们都是朋友，我爱这些家伙，我们能花很多时间在一起，那是一种祝福，伙计。是啊。所以，伊森，谢谢你做这个。听到你说话真好。谢谢你们邀请我，大家。感激不尽。真是太荣幸了。谢谢你，伙计。祝
exactly what the interviewer wants you to say. Do you remember in 1998, you told Rolling Stone magazine, remember, remember, say that again. Right. Right. Right. Right. Yeah. No, we're just, we're just three dummies trapped in an elevator with you and we've got, we've got you trapped for an hour. And, and we also, I think all of us understood when you said, you know, it's about the friendships and we're lucky that we get to do this cause we're all friends and I love these guys and we get to spend a lot of time together and that's a blessing, man. Yeah. So, Ethan, thanks for doing this. It's great to hear you talk. Thanks for having me, everybody. Appreciate it. Such a pleasure. Thank you, man. Have
你余下的一天过得愉快。好的，你们也是。保重，伙计。再见。所以我认为他可能是名单上的第一名，呃，我，我想在最后和他成为朋友。就像，是啊，我的意思是，我想和我们在节目中遇到的很多人成为朋友，但他可能是最顶尖的。他看起来太棒了。是啊。是啊。太酷了。而且他，你知道，他有这个新的，呃，纪录片系列，正如他谈到的，是什么，HBO上的《最后的电影明星》，呃，是啊，《最后的电影明星》HBO Max。我的意思是，呃，他就像，当然，当然他们来找他。当然，呃，呃，保罗·纽曼加入了，他的孩子们来找他，因为他就像，正如你所说，他很酷。你想
a good rest of the day. All right, you too guys. Take care, buddy. See ya. So I think he might be top on the list of, uh, I, I want to be friends with him at the end of it. Like, yeah, I mean, I want to be friends with a lot of people that we meet on the show, but he might be tip top. He just seems so damn great. Yeah. Yeah. So cool. And he, you know, he's got this new, uh, docu series as he talked about the, what is it, the last movie stars on HBO, uh, yeah, the last movie stars HBO Max. I mean, uh, he's just like, of course, of course they came to him. Of course, uh, uh, Paul Newman joined, his kids came to him because he's just, like you said, he's cool. You want to
祝你余下的一天过得愉快。好的，你们也是。保重，伙计。再见。我觉得他可能是我最想在节目结束后和他成为朋友的人名单上的第一名。我是说，我们节目里遇到的很多人我都想和他们成为朋友，但他可能是最顶尖的。他看起来真是太棒了。是啊，是啊。太酷了。而且，你知道，他有一个新的纪录片系列，正如他所提到的，叫什么来着，HBO的《最后的电影明星》，对，HBO Max的《最后的电影明星》。我是说，他就像是，当然，当然他们会找他。当然，保罗·纽曼加入了，他的孩子们来找他，因为就像你说的，他很酷。你想要
hang out with him and he's the kind of guy you'd want telling, you know. Do you want to see that documentary just cause there's a photo of me in it? Hmm. Again, he didn't really react to that. Do you notice that? Cause I mean, I don't think Ethan's seen it. No. Yeah. I don't think he's seen it. But he kind of, he kind of nodded. And I think that he was sort of, I think he thought like, I don't think he's positive who you are. No. By the way, I don't disagree with you. It's the hell in the glasses. Yeah. Um, but seriously, his, his brain, his, his soul spirit, whatever you want to call it seems just. Is this the second time today you brought up soul?
和他待在一起，他就是那种你会想让他去讲述的人，你知道吧。你想看那部纪录片仅仅是因为里面有我的照片吗？嗯。再说一次，他对此并没有什么反应。你注意到了吗？因为我的意思是，我不觉得伊森看过。没有。是啊。我不觉得他看过。但他有点，他有点点头了。我觉得他当时大概是，我觉得他在想，我不觉得他确定你是谁。没有。顺便说一句，我并不反对你的看法。是那副眼镜的问题。嗯，但说真的，他的大脑，他的灵魂精神，无论你想怎么称呼它，似乎只是。这是你今天第二次提到灵魂了吗？
Soul, yeah. What's happening to you right now? I'm just trying to get myself to a place where I can say his heart and everything just seems so bionic. Bionic! Bionic! I don't think we've used that one. Bionic! Bionic! Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass. SmartLass is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. SmartLass. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
灵魂，是的。你现在是怎么了？我只是想让自己达到一种状态，可以说他的心和一切看起来都太仿生了。仿生！仿生！我觉得我们还没用过这个词。仿生！仿生！SmartLass。SmartLass。SmartLass 是由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Amjarf 百分之百有机且手工制作的。SmartLass。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。